il a posté cette dernière vidéo dans
laquelle il explique qu'en mettant en
scène une des soldats sur un théâtre
d'opérations qu'il est très difficile au
pouvoir un possible de rire de tout sur
internet on regarde un petit extrait de
cette vidéo soldat laforêt derrière vous
et d'en déterminer les plus dangereux de
ce siècle
c'est internet mission est très simple
vers une blague sur internet beaucoup
essayé très peu en sont revenus vivants
religions ethnies homosexualité
féminisme politique sujets sont très
sensibles au mieux passé aventurer
mais c'est le blog est subtil et bien
fait sergent s'étend le malin soldats
tant pis tout à blaye
[Musique]
les femmes mais tutorat se préparer
jérémy ponthieu nous a rejoint jérémy
vous faites partie de la dream team des
réseaux sociaux sur lefigaro.fr
alors cette vidéo elle est déjà été vu
par 3 millions de personnes
c'est pour ça qu'on vous parle pas d'un
truc anecdotique enfin ça l'est
peut-être mais en tout cas c'est parce
que ça a dit quelque chose
pourquoi est-ce que ça fait autant de
bruit ce dossier alors ça fait autant de
bruit pour une raison toute simple c'est
que norman effectivement ça fait bien
des années qu'il est sur youtube c'était
un des pionniers est en réalité c'est un
youtube heures qui a fait beaucoup de
vidéo sur des sujets un peu de la vie de
tous les jours des sujets assez léger et
qui a un public depuis des agents reste
il faut préférer le barbecue par la
tulette vidéo de mon chat des vidéos sur
l'effet team ans lara clette les
adhérents sur les forfaits alors des
canulars au téléphone il est moins connu
pour ça mais c'est vrai qu'il a fait
souvent des vidéos voilà où il
intervient sur des sujets et il est vrai
que le point d'accrochage c'est l'un des
points d'accroché celui ci c est de dire
pourquoi norman thavaud qui a toujours
fait des sketches assez léger finalement
dans lequel il n'a jamais eu à rendre
des comptes ou à se défendre sur ses
propos vient parler de ce sujet là c'est
l'un des arguments qui est avancé par
ceux qui sont en avant de cette cette
contestation qu'il assure cette dernière
vidéo est contestée il est quoi il est
contestée parce que j'ai beaucoup de
gens qui disent mais parce qu'en gros ce
qu'ils disent et on n'a pas le temps de
faire des blagues si elles peuvent être
sexy et misogyne homophobe raciste en
tout cas considérés comme tels et damien
sargue manque de gens sur les réseaux
sociaux qui sont choqués en disant oui
c'est vrai c'est pas bien on se moque
des gens qui sont déjà discriminées par
ailleurs car mais il vous est très
présent sur les réseaux sociaux
rappelez moi le dollar sans twitter ça
me rend fou de jalousie
mais le constat de norman thavaud il est
pas faux ça que c'est vrai que l'humour
surtout quand il est un peu limite tout
un peu transgressif sur internet ça
marche pas très fort mais cinq ans plus
tôt c'est mal acceptée c'est pas
accepter du tout ça ne marche pas du
tout bon nombre de fois où en lisant un
tweet ou en me disant en écoutant un
politique je vais faire de l'humour est
en fait il faut se retenir il faut
tourner cette fois l'essai doit avant
d'avant de tweets et et on a plusieurs
exemples de confrères et consoeurs qui
ayant voulu faire de l'humour se sont
pris mais des tombereaux d'insultés
parce que le problème c'est que les gens
considèrent sur twitter facebook les
réseaux sociaux qui sont égalité avec
les politiques avec les journalistes
parce qu'au fond chacun peut écrire le
même nombre de signes chacun a le droit
d'être la même chose et donc du coup ça
donne tout ça avec aussi un élément qui
moi m'horripile à chaque fois c'est que
les gens se cachent derrière des
pseudonymes
et c'est vraiment une spécialité
française et ça m'agace de voir qu'un
certain nombre de confrères et consoeurs
trouve ça très bien parce que sinon les
pauvres ils ne pourraient pas s'exprimer
et je trouve que c'est ça aussi qui
donne lieu à toutes ces insultes parce
que je pense que si les gens mettaient
leurs vraies photos et leur vrai nom il
serait peut-être plus décent or je crois
que je vous donne deux réactions comme
ça sur sur à la vidéo de norman ce n'est
pas la liberté d'expression pour les
gens qui font des blagues sur les noirs
les arabes les lgbt ce n'est pas la
libération de la liberté d'expression
qu'ils veulent c'est l'impunité un point
c'est tout norman sort du silence pour
regretter de comptes puissent pas rire
aux dépens des minorités tu peut
remballer tes vidéos
alexis lacroix un point de vue sur ce
sur cette polémique je vais vous dire si
c'est une polémique pour garder le sang
froid c'est plutôt marrant la vidéo elle
même moi ne me choque absolument pas je
pense quand même un clin d'oeil il ya
même un second degré il ne faut pas je
crois à s'énerver et prendre ça au pied
de la lettre
néanmoins je vais vous dire il ya du
faux dans l'est du fis il ya du faux
dans cette dénonciation là je ne suis
absolument pas le défenseur autoproclamé
du politiquement correct à l'américaine
mais voilà mais je crois qu'il y a
aujourd'hui dans si vous voulez dans
cette voie là au fond j'ai un certain
nombre de gens qui disent il faut qu'on
puisse rire de tout il ya le désir de
faire sauter certaines inhibitions
sociale et donc je ne vois pas pourquoi
ça serait impropre mais oui je ne vois
pas pourquoi ça serait un problème je ne
vois pas pourquoi ça serait un problème
qu'internet bridge jusqu'à un certain
point notre liberté d'expression sur un
certain nombre de sujets relatifs aux
minorités j'en terminerai par là et donc
ce que je sens c'est que cet auditeur a
absolument raison
il y a des gens attendent et il y a des
gens il y a des gens qui rient de bon
coeur à ses plaisanteries sans arrière
pensée il y en ad'autres minoritaire
certes mais il y existe qui voudrait
qu'on puisse à nouveau à matisse pour
les yeux rires non je ne suis pas pour
la basilique je pense et comment tu vas
désiré qui allume un bon rire et quel
est le mauvais riche et la plus dure de
principe de précaution je pense que
norman là il fait non il fait le
politique mais qui fait
politiquement correct a expliqué à ma
petite soeur donc ça c'est rigolo en
revanche les implications concrètes de
cette démarche
je demande à vous attachant g non c'est
pas lui mais jamais les pieds là 3 qui
vient de dire ça si c'est moi oh non
mais franchement ce qui est en jeu c'est
beaucoup plus grave que ça si les gens
ne sont pas capables de comprendre le
second degré c'est quand même qu' il ya
une sorte de déclin intellectuel et
culturel terrible ce que je vois c'est
une fracture générationnelle parce qu'en
réalité pour nous il enfonce des portes
ouvertes normal ça fait des années qu'on
raconte tout ça ça fait des années qu'on
pleure la disparition du second degré ça
fait des années qu'on n'en peut plus de
la bien pensante et de la chape de plomb
qu'elle soit sur internet ou ailleurs
parce qu'on peut plus faire une seule
blague que tex s'est fait virer pour une
blague que moi personnellement je
trouvais drôle en plus parce que les
mauvaises blagues ça me fait rire donc
s'il est on est dans un monde où il ya
une police de l'humour et alexis lacroix
que j'attendais sur son vaillant
destrier en train de défendre la liberté
dit qu'ils ont raison que ce que le
principe de précaution mais non mais
écoutez d'abord quand on voit cette
vidéo on peut pas ne pas comprendre
je le dis jamais ce que rigolo quand je
vois que tu te la jouer une partie de
notre jeunesse des ongles inquiète parce
qu'elle est prude elle et puritaine et
maintenant les gnangnan
ça va pas du tout dans les jeunes
c'était mieux avant jérémy je ne vais
pas faire la limite l'unanimité non plus
je ne pars pas du tout mon point de vue
personnel juste une deuxième point
d'accroché sur cette polémique
elle vient d'une autre d'un autre point
qui a été mis en relief c'est que donc
effectivement norman dit on ne peut plus
rire de tout et certains lui reprochent
j'entends bien certain sur cette
polémique là de d'utiliser en rebours
des de l'humour qu'il considère comme
désuet alors après le débat est là aussi
coin alors et justement sur les blacks
qu'ils considèrent comme aux questions
des femmes des juifs des noirs des
petits des grands des sur quoi on rigole
des rôles des gros des sur quoi on va
rire je veux dire mais en tous les cas
moi je pense si vous voulez pour ceux
pour la minorité disons à laquelle
j'appartiens je pense que ce serait
terrible qu'on puisse plus faire des
blagues sur les juifs
c'était visible ci voulait il ya plus
si on peut plus rigoler ensemble mais
termine sa je termine peut-être en
apportant un contraste à ça c'est qu'il
est vrai que si l'on s'en fie aux
commentaires de la vidéo il y a eu aussi
un soutien dans l'autre sens en verre
norman il faut pas non plus c'est vrai
forcément ou un peu longue mais il ya eu
un nom qui ne pourraient polémique et
qui naquit de ça beaucoup de discussions
il y en a aussi qui justement prennent
le parti de dire il faut rire de tout et
certains autres qui leur disent voilà il
faut rire de tout mais pas avec tout le
moins cher rené girard maintenant que
vous savez qui est normal
vous avez joué sur ce sujet alors moi
j'ai envie de dire
l'idée des journaux à réaliser des
livres fermer les boutiques de fringues
rouvre librairie aller au lycée
franck fait la cagne voilà est
effectivement tout ce monde de la
rapidité de l'internet du message
twitter j'ai quarante cinq mille les
45000 ou 450 milles ou quatre millions
et demi et je hais je twitte pour voir
qui me suit tout fameux 100 bahts
éthique sociale ensemble youtube youtube
youtube c'est rossi alors là c'est en
cet arrêt ben oui eh bah pourquoi moi si
tu peux rien du tout je dis juste un mot
entre ce jeudi gérard moi je vous passe
la parole pour dire que youtube c'est
aussi un des supports qui diffuse point
de vue et qui permet à tous nos
internautes comme twitter d'avoir accès
aux analyse passionnante de renaud
girard et quart mais je rajoute juste un
bémol c'est que le figaro et l'express
sont sur twitter et ont plusieurs
millions d'abonnés donc comme quoi
malgré tous ces réseaux session que vous
pouvez trouver pathétique mal ne le sont
pas tant que ça c'est purement subjectif
ça n'engage que moi ça n'empêche pas mon
journal ni une ni un courant de pensée
dont je serai le porte à titre personnel
je suis comme gir 1 c'est à dire que la
fuite en avant dans l'exhibition de soi
pour gagner les suffrages électronique
il ça ne m'a jamais excité et j'allais
dire c'est même ça me fait un peu peur
donc sur des réseaux sociaux j'en suis
très content les jurys question et
l'italie 5 étrangères
l'édification la donne ensuite je suis
je suis je j'utilise et je trouve ça
très pratique effectivement les sms
comme tout le monde et même on peut très
bien diffuser des messages des messages
très attendu
surfer sur facebook et que je suis le
premier à me réjouir de google mais je
considère que l'édification d'une
politique étrangère à coup de messages
de 140 2 ou 146 caractère est une
régression pas têtus que c'est notre
message c'est un record personnel de
cette émission est tard vous avez dix
voire vingt secondes très rapidement
juste pour dire effectivement que sur
youtube aurait aussi vous intéresser à
d'autres créateurs et sur le figaro on
en a parlé à travers les créatures du
web une série qu'on a